suffering is a resistance to the pain
what you resist persist right so
I know that some people out there have a
predisposition to a condition called
oneitis which is an unhealthy attachment
to
um a woman usually usually a woman
that's no good for you usually a woman
that you're stuck with because you
didn't have better choices usually a
woman that you invite into your life
because
you didn't have better options you know
which is you know fault of your own at
the end of the day but a lot of guys
will
resist the pain you know of what they
created in their life oh she betrayed me
she cheated on me look we've all been
there I've been there you've been there
a lot of a lot of you dudes watching
right now even some of the gals watching
look
when you resist the pain the suffering
continues right what you resist is
always going to persist
lean into it made some stupid choices
why did I invite this crazy [__] in my
life oh she had those red flags and that
one too and this one too you can hear
I'm gonna put the ticker up on the
bottom get on my email list so you can
get the red flag chapter if you don't
want to buy the buckets right here you
can get it for free all right she had
this red flag she had that red flag oh
okay oh and then I did that when I
shouldn't have done that oh and I was
sipping for oh and I did this stupid
[__] you know with their kids or for her
kids or whatever and that Amplified the
situation you kind of sit back and you
go okay
I don't really want to suffer with this
anymore I'm not going to resist this
pain it is what it is I did it you kind
of move on for and that's how you move
on from one itis by taking ownership and
evaluating the situation guys are
incredibly good at rationalizing things
so use that skill
another thing to do is eliminate the
importance
of anything that causes pain in your
life or things that you perceive to be
painful
right
you have air in your lungs good you got
food in your belly good
you got clean fresh drinking water yep
got a roof over your head yep
your life's probably better than like
I'd say 85 percent of the world a lot of
a lot of the world lives in extreme
poverty we don't have they don't have a
proper roof for that they don't have
clean drinking water they get they drink
shitty water and end up with all kinds
of gut diseases and stuff like that
eliminate the importance of the pain
doesn't matter does this really matter
does this really matter ask yourself
that question does this person really
matter
do I need to suffer because of what
happened here in this transaction
Dynamic relationship my boss fired me my
business partner took advantage of me
that [__] cheated on me with Kevin from
sales the you know whatever it happens
to be right
eliminate the importance of it
[__] my boss I'm gonna go do it on my
own and start my own company I'm going
to prove I'm wrong that's that's one of
the reasons why I started up my debt
business right
I was just looking at the industry and
I'm like [__] those guys I'm going to do
it better I have a better way to make
money I have a better way to solve this
problem I have a better way to help
people
right
like use the pain
don't let it use you don't let it own
you don't let it take over your life
don't let it consume your bandwidth
don't let it you know become your
identity that's what a lot of people do
it's like oh like
I want to see if I can find it real
quick on my Twitter feed
if I can find it I'm just gonna put it
up on the screen I'm not going to say it
because this is how the YouTubes are but
let me see if I can find this real quick
hard to swallow pills
oh man
there's so much of this out there
or is it hard to swallow pills that I
came across the other day
come on scroll scroll scroll
there they are
share on the screen
oh my life is miserable nobody likes me
everything's difficult I should have
been born this way or that way
it's gonna put it up on the screen
okay I'm gonna take it off the screen
it's kind of the world we live in today
it's like you know
eliminate the importance of it stop
[__] around with your life doing
stupid things over things that are
insignificant and not important that's
really what a lot of us do I've done it
I have the T-shirt been there done it
have the graduated degree trust me
you don't it doesn't need to become you
doesn't need to be your identity you
don't need to keep making the same
stupid mistakes over and over again the
definition of insanity is doing the same
thing again and again expecting a
different result stop it
foreign
comes from wanting things to be
different you understand
we want things to be different we want
things to go our way and if they don't
we have to suffer
no you don't
you really don't find a solution
in the solution
or find contentment find happiness in it
eliminate the importance of it
does it really matter is it really worth
losing sleep over
right
suffering comes from wanting things to
be different let it sink in marinate on
that for a minute surrender to what it
is and stop craving for things to be
totally different from what they
actually are
another thing
people like to do a lot
is attaching
suffering to pain it's like painful boom
oh now I have to suffer I get it we do
it naturally even as children stub your
toe your sibling punches you in the eye
start somewhere it all starts somewhere
for someone and then you want to attach
suffering to that pain but the reality
of it like like parents even know like
when kids have a little spaz and they
have a meltdown over
hurting their finger or touching
something hot and they and they drag it
on for like a long period of time longer
than what it needs to be like they know
the Pain's gone like it's enough okay we
can stop the charades we're not trying
to win an Oscar here nobody gives a [__]
you're not going to win an Oscar for
attaching you're suffering to some
painful moment in your life to some
chaos stop attaching suffering to pain
you can detach them eliminate the
significance of it it probably doesn't
matter
I guarantee there's going to be hundreds
of thousands of people in the world out
there with that that probably change
exchange their shitty scenario they're
worse off even shittier scenario
whatever you think is is is the end of
your day week month year or whatever you
know it happens to be you know we like
to create stories in our minds about
suffering in certain ways that
you know let you know it's like the
oppression
the oppression Olympics you know these
these guys are like well we're the most
marginalized group no we're the most
marginalized group no you have it this
way and you've all got all these
advantages well you because of this and
your grandfathers did that to our people
and it just goes on and on and on right
it's like dude get over it man get over
it get over it take ownership for your
life and do better and be better that's
part of the problem with the world today
I'm I'm telling you right now you can uh
bone broth
trying to drink more bone broth into
evening anyway
in case you're wondering I know
everybody always asks in the comments
what you drinking man
don't do it
pain is mandatory suffering is optional
realize that go back and watch this over
and over again until it sinks in I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out